hallo leute hier ist wieder eure mal
wann es ist wieder soweit halloween
steht vor der tür
wer mich kennt weiß es gleich nach
weihnachten mein lieblings fest ist
während andere in meinem alter niere
rentenvorsorge denken denkt ich halt ein
cooles halloween-kostüm egal ich werde
schon irgendwann erwachsen sein lange
rede gar keinen sinn ich als alter
halloween profi habe mich mal hingesetzt
meine grauen zellen angeregt und nicht
ganz besondere verkleidung für mich
ausgeht glaubt mir leute mit diesen
ideen werdet ihr der hit auf jeder party
seien außer die party bestätigt muss man
zuschauen dann sähe die vielleicht alle
gleich aus für den staat habe ich für
meine potter hetzt da draußen eine super
einfache und schnelle idee zieht euch
alles goldene an was sie auftreiben
können und am ende rundet ihr es mit
einem paar flügeln ab und so leicht seid
ihr der staat aber passt auch dass ich
auf eurer party keine suche herumtreiben
denn sonst heißt es
abhauen oder schwammartige terry potter
verkleidet dann macht das kostüm noch
mehr sind sich einen snapshot filter ins
gesicht zu malen ist keine idee dies
nicht schon hundertmal gab aber wie
sieht es mit dem facebook filter auch
dafür schminkt ihr euer gesicht zudem
einer bekannten filmfigur und hängt euch
das foto von dieser person um den hals
damit es auch ein richtiger facebook
wird klebt ihr jetzt euer gesicht auf
das foto und schon seid ihr fertig also
für diese idee
da könnt ihr mich jetzt aber mal
ordentlich hier in den kommentaren loben
wer es richtig einfach und bequem mag
der sollte jetzt aufpassen
zieht euch einen grauen wollen sie an
und klärt euch kleine grasbüschel auf
alte schule und was seid ihr ein
unbekanntes pokemon und falls ihr keinen
grauen
ihr habt könnt ihr euch einfach eine
graue hose ein graues sweatshirt und
eine graue mütze anziehen und schon seid
ihr fertig großer vorteil hat definitiv
das gemütlichste kostüm von allen hier
müsst ihr wieder ein bisschen basteln
schneidet euch aus einem stück pappe
einen kreis und einen pfeil aus marl sie
rot anlass sie gut durchtrocknen und
dann klebt ihr den pfeil mitte spitze
zum gesicht auf eure brust im kreis
befestigt ihr dann mit einem haarreifen
vor euer gesicht optional könnt ihr euch
noch müll an den körper kleben und schon
seid ihr die youtube trend seite für das
nächste kostüm braucht ihr ein bettlaken
und eine schere
legt euch das bettlaken über den kopf
markiert euch wo eure augen sind und
schneidet dann zwei löcher seien
anschließend nehmt ihr euch ein bisschen
rote farbe und malt sie dorthin wo
europol und schon seid ihr der geist
eines mädchens das in der schule zum
ersten mal ihre tage bekommen hat und
dann vor scham gestorben ist comedy
wer ein bisschen talent und geduld fürs
schminken mitbringt aber keine lust hat
auf diese 08 15 standard halloween
gesichter wie vampire teufel zombie
trittin habe ich etwas dafür braucht ihr
nur künstliche wimpern und ein paar
farben schritt eins ihr macht euch ein
auge ins gesicht schritt 2 ihr klebt
eine wimper dran und das macht ihr so
oft ihr wollt das ergebnis ist jedes mal
einzigartig und ganz schön verwirrend
big brother is watching you
wenn du dir nicht sicher bist was du an
dem abend sein möchtest kein problem
alle die über die komplette stirn eine
narbe oder du benutzt wie ich ein tattoo
dafür jetzt besorgt du dir nur noch ein
gehirn und trägst es auf der party mit
iro wenn da niemand fragt was du bist
hast du die auswahl ein rassist ein
falsches sex ist donald trump oder
frauke petry deiner fantasie sind keine
grenzen gesetzt
kannst auch du dich mal wieder nicht
entscheiden ob du ein witziges oder sexy
kostüm tragen will
dafür habe ich die lösung braucht dafür
nur ein stück pappe verschiedene
acrylfarben und bänder das stück pappe
teils du in gleich große quadrate ein
und malz diese in verschiedenen höhen
dann machst du zwei löcher rein und
befestigt es mit bändern an deinem
körper jetzt noch einen hohen rock oder
eine highways hose dazu und es sieht so
aus als ob du oben rum nix an hättest
witzig und sexy wenn du dich über eine
bestimmte gruppe von menschen lustig
machen willst dann setzte die reine
pinocchio nase auf und bastelt die einen
presseausweis grüne alles zum schluss
mit einem hut und schon bist du die
fiese und gemeine lügen presse immer
diese lügen presse die lügt meine letzte
idee kannst du auch als last minute
aktion nehmen setzte die reine cap
aufziehe die ein neuartiges t shirt an
und betone mit lila braun farben deiner
augenringe und fertig internet do your
sting
ich hoffe wirklich dass euch meine ideen
gefallen haben und wenn ja dann lasst es
mich auf jeden fall wissen und falls ihr
noch coole kostümideen habt schreibt sie
in die kommentare
dann können sich andere da mal was raus
bieten von sido nicht wissen was sie an
halloween tragen werden ich wünsche euch
auf jeden fall eine schöne party falls
sie halloween feiert und wir sehen uns
dann das nächste mal
bis dann tschüss
wir hoffen euch hat das video befallen
wenn ja dann abonniert doch den kanal
bis dann
nun gibt und euren abgetrennten daumen
nach oben